all right switching gears here to talk
about our weather and let me just start
off it seems like it's a blue type of
date yes but there's nothing blue about
the weather because i'm enjoying it in
the morning yeah it just gets really hot
we all got the blue memo in here they
did that in las vegas now too right if
we can only just guess the lotto numbers
we'll be all set are you ready for
tonight's feature movie here we go guys
and we're going to show you today we're
going to the drive-in
bringing this graphic back
tonight's feature top gun
joists starring k.j
christian all right
everyone like that one student i've got
a lot more than i thought we went in the
studio a lot more last all right
christians coaching kj's one right there
here's what you can expect for tonight
it's going to be a nice warm night
tonight in those 80s 87 degrees 8 p.m 9
p.m 83 10 p.m 81 degrees mostly clear
your wind's also calming down too
currently outside
it's warm out there but it's going to
obviously get hotter as we get through
the week 88 for centennial hills 87 sky
canyon 89 north las vegas same for
sunrise matter 90 for whitney ranch 85
southern highlands 90 henderson anthem
you're at double eights right now too so
warm out there not too bad unless you're
out in death valley where yeah you're a
triple digits for sure 102 out there in
enol county 89 for a prompt 60 i should
actually that's more in the high 80s for
a mesquite searchlight six in the 80s
also for searchlight i'm going to have
to adjust those numbers for you outside
right now satellite radar composite does
show some showers look at this
convection going on towards the east of
us but that's not bringing us any rain
here as we stay on the dry side right
now that's all going to change though as
far as the temperatures outside right
now
precip we're still going to stay dry but
what we're going to see is this this is
a ridge in the jet stream and this
amplifies even more over the region on
wednesday and thursday that's going to
bring us some good heat all right before
we start to see those numbers knocked
down and breezy winds return
by thursday friday heading into your
holiday weekend your winds though these
next few days not too bad tomorrow in
fact most of the area should be light
with those gustier winds down the
colorado valley at your tuesday here's
your wednesday it'll pick up just a
little bit more but we'll have just some
light breezes expected for wednesday the
stronger winds the pickup again we think
like we said on thursday especially in
the afternoon so here's your forecast 67
degrees overnight mild mostly clear
lighter winds tonight after those breezy
winds we had this morning 94 for
tomorrow so warmer tomorrow
clear just a little bit above average
from we should be should be in the low
90s this time of year light winds for
tomorrow like we pin pointed out to you
highs neighborhood neighborhood now in
the mid 90s across the valley here
from centennial hills spring valley 93
green valley here 96 93 north las vegas
southern highlands 93 92 for henderson
outside the valley hotter for you in
death valley 107 tomorrow 102 for
laughlin and 92 for our good friends
that are watching us from boulder city
eight day forecast you're eight on the
eight take a look those temperatures
will peak on thursday 102. that's the
hottest day of the year so far it looks
like we're gonna match that again and
then we're gonna see those numbers drop
as we get to your holiday weekend look
at that 93 for memorial day coming up
i'll talk about how strong those winds
will get this week i'll show you when
they'll peak and when they'll start to
decrease more that's all coming up in
your most accurate forecast kj